hello this is nano danau at dev dungeon
comm and we're going to walk through the
process of creating a discord bot in
JavaScript with nodejs there's a written
tutorial on dev dungeon if you prefer
the blogpost format check the
description for a link we're gonna start
at the very beginning with how to
register with discord and create your
own server all the way through creating
custom commands adding emoji reactions
to messages and more also check out some
of the other tutorials for discord that
are available including how to write
discord bots in python if you aren't
already familiar with discord it is a
great text and voice chat platform
that's free to use they have a web
mobile and a desktop app it has a lot of
nice features for gamers in particular
dev dungeon has a discord server you can
join to chat about programming and
security related topics here's a link
and you can also find it in the video
description and from the dev dungeon
home page the first thing you'll need to
do is register and then log in to
discord go to https colon slash slash
discord app comm slash channels slash at
me once you're logged in the next step
is to create a server for you to test
with look on the left side for the
server list and click the plus sign then
click create a server you will need to
fill out a name at a minimum you can
also provide an image and change the
region if desired I recommend picking
the region closest to you for faster
server responses after your server is
created it should show up in the left
side in your server list click on the
server you should see a general channel
and on the member list to the right you
should see your user now that you have
your very own server to mess around with
you will need to register an app with
discord go to the discord developer
portal at discord app comm slash
developers and then click on create an
application fill out the name of your
application by default it's named my
application but you should give it a
custom name
then click on the bot section in the
left and choose add bot change the bots
name if you want to then under the token
section of the bot page click on click
to reveal and save this token this is
essentially your BOTS username and
password combined into one string so
it's important to keep this a secret and
don't share it with anybody you don't
want to control your bot I'm showing
mine for this tutorial only but I will
be deleting it afterwards so nobody can
use it later you will use this token in
the source code so save it now that you
have a server an app and a bot user
there's one more step we have to do with
this cord your bot can be invited to
many servers but right now it doesn't
belong to any server so we'll need to
invite the bot to your server click on
the to section on the left side of the
page and then scroll down slightly to
the scopes section check the box scope
and it will generate a URL copy that URL
and paste it into your web browser once
on the page you'll be asked which server
you want to invite the bot to choose the
server that you created and click
authorize
once you see the authorized success
screen your bot has successfully joined
your server you should now see the bots
in the member list as an offline user
the same URL that you used to authorize
the bot can be shared with others if you
want them to invite your bot to their
server they'll be able to interact with
your bot but not control your bot now
we're done with all the prep work needed
on the discord side
fortunately you only have to do all of
this one time once the bot is created
and invited to the server it will stay
there you won't have to do this again
now we can move on to writing the
JavaScript code before we can do that
though you need to make sure you have no
js' installed on your system
open your system terminal and run node -
- version if you get a response and it
says 8.0 or higher you're already good
to go but if you get a message like
unrecognized program or some kind of
error you most likely need to go
download and install node J s get it
from nodejs org after you have installed
nodejs
you should be able to run node - -
version in your terminal and it should
look something like this next I'm going
to open visual studio code a free editor
that works well with JavaScript you can
use any editor you want though but this
is the one I'm going to use for the
tutorial and I recommend you use it to
follow along as well unless you already
have a preferred editor go to file open
folder I recommend creating a new
directory to store your project I'm
going to create a new directory on my
desktop called my bot then I'm going to
choose to open that folder
once the folder is open you can hover
your mouse over the folder name in the
left sidebar and click on the new file
icon give the file name like my bot J s
the next thing we need to do is install
the disk or das module using NPM go to
view terminal and a terminal opened up
in the bottom portion of your editor
window it should automatically put you
in the directory that you opened and
you're working in in the terminal run
NPM install disk or j/s you might see
some warnings and that's okay there
shouldn't be any errors though at the
time of this video version 11 is the
latest disk or j/s version future
versions may change and break some of
these examples so if that happens check
out the video description and the
comments to see if there's any updates
ok now we finally have all the setup
work out of the way we can actually
start coding congratulations if you made
it this far you've got most of the
legwork out of the way let's go back to
our file that we created let's write a
very simple bot program just to make
sure everything is installed properly
and the bot user is working correctly
we will load the discord module and then
connect that's all it's going to do when
the bot successfully connects we will
have it print out a message to the
console indicating that it did connect
in the file write Const discord equals
require discord KS and on the next line
write Const client equals new discord
dot client
then let's add some code that will get
triggered after the bot has successfully
connected right the following code
client dot on ready parentheses arrow
console.log connected as plus client
user dot tag then finally one more line
where we call client login pass your
bots secret token has the parameter to
login if you need to get your bots token
again go to discord app comm slash
developers click on your application and
then go to the bot section and click to
reveal the token
pass the token as a string to the client
login function let's test this now by
executing the program in the terminal
using node Maybach Jas we should see a
message printed out to our console to
indicate success and if we look at our
server the bot user should appear online
if you see the message in your console
and the bot appears online then congrats
everything is installed correctly and
your bot is configured properly the
hardest parts are all out of the way now
now we're gonna focus on making your bot
do fun things if you happen to get an
error message read the message carefully
and see if you can figure out why it
failed if you get stuck join the dev
dungeon discord server or leave a
comment here also check the comments to
see if your question is already answered
to terminate the program press control-c
this will end the program and return you
to the command prompt after you
terminate the program your bot will
appear online for a few minutes before
it goes back offline that's normal let's
modify the code so after the bot
connects we have it updated status to
say that it's playing a game near the
bottom of the on ready event write
client user dot set activity and pass it
a string that says with JavaScript this
will change the bot status to say
playing with JavaScript let's run it and
verify it works
it looks like the bots status did update
good you can change the verb from
playing to streaming listening or
watching let's change it to say watching
YouTube instead of playing with
JavaScript let's remove the line we
currently have and replace it with
client user dot set activity YouTube and
as the second parameter we're going to
pass it type watching let's run it again
and make sure it works as expected
perfect now let's extend the bot a
little further to print out the list of
all the servers that it's connected to
right now it's probably only connected
to your one server but it's possible
that the bot belongs to many servers at
once inside the ready event let's add a
few lines of code write client Guild's
dot for each guild arrow console.log
guild dot name
let's run it and verify it works we
should see our test server listed at a
minimum let's take it a little further
and for each server let's have it print
out all of the available channels inside
that for each loop that we already
created right guild channels dot for
each channel arrow console.log channel
name channel type channel ID
let's run it again and view the output
we should see a list of channels for
each server listed notice that there are
multiple types of channels including
text voice and category let's look for a
text channel there's one called general
take note of the ID we're going to need
this for later in the next steps you can
add it as a comment to the existing code
so you don't lose it
each channel and channel ID is unique
per server so you cannot use this exact
ID that I'm using in my example you'll
have to use the ID that you got from
your own program on your server why
don't we have the bot send a message to
the general channel that we just
identified in the previous step whenever
it connects we'll make it say hello
world at the bottom of the on ready
event block right let general channel
equals client channels get and pass it
the ID of your channel as a string on
the next line write general channel dot
send
hello world
let's run the program again and make
sure it works verify it sends a hello
world message after it connects
next let's demonstrate how to attach a
file or an image to a message you send
it's very similar to sending a message
except instead of passing a string we're
going to pass an attachment object we
can create an attachment by writing
const attachment equals new discord
attachment we need to pass either a file
name or a web URL to a file this works
the same for files and images you can
pass it a local file path to something
on your hard disk or an internet address
I'm going to provide a URL to the dev
dungeon logo you can use the same URL
since it is publicly accessible now on
the line where we call general channel
dot send let's replace the string of
hello world with the attachment object
we just created
let's run the code and see what happens
as expected it posted the image to the
channel okay so now we have seen how to
get a list of servers get a list of
channels send a message send an image
update the bot status but what if we
want to respond to an incoming message
from someone else so far we've been
triggering all of our code based off of
the ready event which is triggered after
the bot connects and is ready to perform
actions we're going to start using a
different event now one that is
triggered every time a message is sent
that is the message event below the
entire client ready event let's write
client dot on message received message
arrow open and close bracket right now
we'll leave it empty so let's fill out
the logic that we want to happen
whenever a message is received the
message event is triggered on every
single message that means even messages
that the bot sends out will trigger this
event this could potentially send the
bot into an infinite loop where it
continues responding to its own messages
forever to avoid this let's add a check
to see if the message author is the bot
itself if it is we will just ignore it
and return and as get the function so it
doesn't do anything do this by writing
if received message dot author equals
equals client dot user then return
if the message was sent by someone else
other than the bot the code will
continue past these lines so after this
if statement let's have the bot reply
right received message channel dot send
message received
plus received message content this will
have the bot respond in the same channel
and echo back the message that it got as
acknowledgment this could be a public
channel or a private message it'll work
correctly for both why don't we make the
response a little more personalized
let's have the bot tag the user who sent
the message to do this we just need to
reference the received message dauther
and convert it to a string update the
sent message to include received message
to string like this
let's run it again and make sure that it
works
good it looks like it tags the user who
sent the message
while we're at it why don't we have the
bots at an emoji reaction to the users
message inside the on message event
let's have the bot add a reaction some
servers have custom emojis that you can
use while others only have the default
set believe it or not there is actually
an international standard for emojis you
can check out all of the Unicode emojis
at this link it's also in the video
description to add a reaction we will
write received message dot react and
pass it the emoji string you can
actually copy and paste the emoji itself
into the source code a Unicode emoji is
recognized as a character just like a P
or a Q however this Court does not
support every single Unicode emoji so
you'll have to try it out and make sure
the one that you want works for this
example we'll use the thumbs up which is
known to work you can also use custom
images on your server to add custom
emojis to a server go to server settings
emoji upload emoji I will upload a
sample one now to demonstrate
to use a custom emoji as a reaction you
will need to know the unique ID of the
custom emoji we don't know what that ID
is yet as I just uploaded it so why
don't we just get every custom emoji
from the server print out its ID and
react with it so at the code received
message guild
emojis dot for each custom emoji arrow
console dot log custom emoji name custom
emoji ID and then on the next line
received message react custom emoji
this will go through each custom emoji
available on the server and react with
it as well as print out the ID let's run
it once to see how it works
notice how it reacted with our custom
emoji in the server and in the console
it printed out the ID now that we know
the ID we can just react with that one
specific emoji instead of loading all of
them let's get rid of the four each and
replace it with let custom emoji equals
received message guild emojis dot get
and then D ID on the next line ad
received message react custom emoji
let's run it and send a message again
just to make sure it works
at this point you should feel a little
more comfortable with your bot and have
enough building blocks to build a more
complicated bot I want to cover one last
topic though which is how to create a
command a command in this sense is just
a regular message that starts with a
special character like an exclamation
point that triggers inaction by the bot
there are many ways you can implement
this you could check the entire message
to see if it contains the full command
or you could make the command take a
variable number of parameters I'm gonna
walk through one way to create it that
demonstrates making two commands help
command and a multiply command with
these examples you should have a good
template for extending and creating more
of your own custom commands first let's
start inside the on message event block
since the command will be a message
let's inspect the first character of the
message and see if it equals the
exclamation mark if it does let's pass
the logic off to a function called
process command and let's pass it the
received message as the argument next
we'll need to create the process command
function it takes the received message
as a parameter we already know it starts
with an exclamation point so let's
remove that character from the beginning
of the string with let full command
equals received message content substr
one this will remove the first character
next let's take the remaining string and
split it into pieces based off of each
space character let split command equals
full command dot split and passage of
space this will return an array
containing each word we want to treat
the first word provided as the name of
the command we'll call that the primary
command so right let primary command
equals split command bracket 0 if there
are any remaining words in the array we
want to store them as the arguments let
arguments equal split
command dot slice one this will exclude
the first element and keep all of the
rest of them if there are any so now we
have one variable containing the primary
command and another variable containing
the array of all the arguments if there
are any now we can inspect the primary
command variable to see what command was
triggered since we want to make a help
command let's check and see if the
primary command equals the string help
please an if statement if it does equal
help let's hand off logic to a function
named help command and pass it the
arguments along with the original
message that was received next we will
have to create the help command function
let's do that now function help command
and pass it arguments received message
inside the help command we can inspect
the argument list to see if any
arguments were provided let's first
check to see if the length is zero
meaning no parameters were provided if
arguments dot length equals equals zero
then received message channel dot send
I'm not sure what you need help with try
exclamation help topic
if the user didn't provide any arguments
we'll let them know by responding with
that message let's also add an else
statement to handle the case when
arguments are passed in this case we'll
just respond saying it looks like you
need help with plus arguments
let's run this and try it out now try
typing exclamation help and then
exclamation help javascript and review
the responses from the bots
let's add a second command so you get
the idea of how to add more commands
back in the processed command function
let's add an else if statement to check
for another command named multiply if it
is let's hand off logic to a function
named multiply command let's also add an
else statement to catch any unknown
commands and suggest some possible
commands to the user
next we need to create the multiply
command function function multiply
command arguments received message
the first thing we should do is check
the arguments we will need at minimum
two values to multiply together let's
write an if statement to check if the
arguments is less than two if it is less
than two let's send a message back to
the user and then exit the function
if there are at Lee
two arguments then the code will
continue past this if statement let's
calculate the product then let product
equals one to start then arguments dot
for each value arrow product equals
product times parsefloat value now that
we have the multiplication product we
can return the answer to the user with
received message channel dot send the
product of arguments is product two
string
now let's test out the multiply command
restart the bot and send exclamation x
itself and then try exclamation multiply
two point five ten and ten and it should
return a result
try adding your own custom command to
the bot if you don't have any ideas try
a simple one where if you write
exclamation ping the bot will respond
with pong
if you need some other ideas for custom
commands' how about an exclamation
fortune command that will return a
random fortune cookie quote or how about
exclamation Bitcoin that will look up
the Bitcoin price using an API and
return the price to the user or her
about exclamation whether that takes the
zip code as an argument and returns the
local weather that's all the code we're
going to cover in this tutorial you're
on your own now you should be able to
take these building blocks and build
better more complex BOTS one common
question is how do I run the bot 24/7
all the time to keep a bot running all
the time you'll need to leave the
program running all the time you can do
this by simply leaving your computer on
all the time and never turning it off
this is not practical for most people
though an alternative is to rent a cheap
$5 a month server from a provider like
Linode or digitalocean they provide
cheap Linux servers that run all the
time in their data center the cloud as
you call it you can run your code there
another alternative is to use something
like a Raspberry Pi from your house and
leave that running all the time if you
have any questions feel free to join the
dev dungeon discord server and ask
questions you can also check the
comments here and leave comments here
also make sure you bookmark the discord
jas official documentation at discord
j/s org that's going to be the best most
definitive source for this library check
out other dev dungeon tutorials on the
youtube channel and on dev dungeon comm
there are several other discord
tutorials including how to write a
discord bot in python thanks for
watching and please subscribe to the
channel